[Music]
legend has it there is a tree in the
Amazon that possesses unparalleled
healing powers and the Arrowhead is the
key to unlocking it
hello I just wanted you to know this has
been mislabeled
[Music]
he's shipping outlets
of all the jungle cruisers you can take
in the Amazon
this one is undoubtedly the cheapest but
also the most thrilling heads up come a
Duke
look out
Marauders
natives ladies and gentlemen the moment
you've all been waiting for
the backside of water stays wonder of
the world
we're headed upriver lagrimas de cristal
mr. Huron travel come on about a good
time my brother and I are looking for
passage upriver please go away
I have a lot of money ever you believe
in legends you should believe in curses
too
you're gonna bake minutes our back well
I look forward to disappointing you
10,000 to bring you there alive dead is
15,000 why should I pay me dead
dead I'd have to carry you that's a lot
harder lady there we go
oh no sorry Frank sorry strong for me
hi Janice when you book the river cruise
and you can't swim
the price just went out
miss Israel
[Music]